لمعرفة المزيد عن الأزمة الإنسانية المتفاقمة
في غزة، دعنا نحضر أه
طيبي مدير الرعاية في الضفة الغربية
وغزة الآن سمعت أنك فقدت
الاتصال بموظفيك داخل غزة، هل قمت
بإعادة الاتصال بهم، تعرف كيف حالهم
اه للأسف فقدنا
الاتصال مع زملائنا
حوالي 30 ساعة ويوم كانت هذه الساعات هي
الأطول في حياتنا والحمد لله
تمكنا من إعادة التواصل معهم
كلهم ​​اه اه محسوب عليهم حتى الآن ما
زالوا في الجنوب ما زالوا في  نفس
الملاجئ وهي أه على الأقل في
الوقت الحالي فهي آمنة ولكن كما تعلم
لا توجد مساحة آمنة في
غزة وماذا تسمع منهم
عن الوضع الأوسع في غزة
عن الوضع الذي يعيشه سكان غزة
الآن للأسف الآن  ما يقرب من 3
أسابيع أصبح الوضع
أكثر فأكثر كارثيًا وقاسيًا، لا
يزال الناس في
الملاجئ، لقد أصبحوا أكثر
ازدحامًا كما تعلمون،
كان على نصف السكان تقريبًا أن يكونوا
نازحين داخليًا وتم إجلاؤهم إلى الجنوب،
ولا يزال هناك  مياه ثابتة لا
مياه شرب آه الوقود هو أنهم يفتقرون إلى إمكانية
الوصول إلى الوقود وهم الآن يطبخون
الغاز أيضًا آه الخبز يتم
تقنينه أيضًا في استخدام الأسرة في جميع
المجتمعات التي لا يمكنهم الوصول إلى
الخدمات الصحية الآن بدأنا نرى
لا يزال الناس يعودون ويعيشون في
أنقاض منازلهم على
السطح لأن الملاجئ لا تستطيع أه أه
استضافتهم بعد الآن، ليس هناك مساحة لهم ونحن نرى
أم لقطات
لأشخاص يذهبون إلى المستودعات للحصول على
الطعام الذي نسمعه  من الناس أن هذا النوع
من المجتمع المدني داخل غزة
ينهار نوعًا ما، هل تسمعون ذلك
أيضًا
أن
المجتمع يتفكك نوعًا
ما لسوء الحظ إذا كنت تستطيع أن
تتخيل أنني لا أستطيع حتى أن أضع نفسي في
موقفهم ونحن في الرعاية على سبيل المثال
نتلقى  مكالمات هاتفية من أشخاص أه أه
عملنا معهم سابقًا في غزة
يطلبون منا أن ندعمهم بالطعام والماء
الآن كل هؤلاء الأشخاص
في الملاجئ لديهم إمكانية الوصول إلى
مبلغ معين من خلال وكالات الأمم المتحدة
مثل أونرا وغيرها وأيضًا من خلال
المنظمات الإنسانية ولكن
هناك الكثير الكثير ممن هم خارج
الملاجئ بما في ذلك في الشمال في
الوسط وفي الجنوب وفي
البداية كان هناك نوع أه من أه
الطعام المخزن داخل العائلات ثم
الإخلاء الحركة تدمير
أثرت البنية التحتية على إمكانية
حصولهم على الغذاء، فهم يفتقرون إلى الأموال النقدية أيضًا، لذا
بدأت جميع المواد الغذائية الموجودة غير
متوفرة في الأسواق، وإذا كان
لدي أطفال يعانون من الجوع والعطش
فسأفعل أي شيء، ولا أضع نفسي
في موقفهم ولكن  لقد مرت الآن 3 أسابيع يا
عزيزتي، وهذا من
الممكن أن لا أستطيع تأكيد ذلك ولكن
من المحتمل أنهم بحاجة إلى طعام وماء